in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Todd
and Cheyenne are with us hey how are you
guys great
welcome welcome good to have you where
are you from from the DFW area in Texas
Dallas Texas all right cool and you're
here to do your debt-free scream yes I
love it how much have you paid off we've
paid off a hundred and four thousand
mm-hmm in four and a half years love
that very good making what kind of range
of income during that time we started
out around 65,000 mm-hmm and at our
highest point we were about 75 80,000
and at the lowest point about 45,000 oh
wow big range okay what kind of debt was
the hundred and four thousand everything
you were normal we had student loans car
lots of credit cards so how long you
guys been married nine years nine years
okay so what happened four and a half
years ago they gave you the wake-up call
well I was reading one of my favorite
blogs and your books were on sale so I
was like I love to shop online so let me
just go ahead and buy them and so I read
the book we did the budget and then we
didn't look at it for six months and so
we reread the book and we did a budget
and then that's when the four and a half
years started okay so that's when it the
second time you went through you got
serious about yes so the total money
makeover was your guide yes okay very
cool very cool so you sit down then you
do the budget what do you think the
difference was the second time you did
the book and the budget that made you
actually do it this time
well we realized that you had to go back
back throughout the month make sure
you're following the budget and then
also making sure that you did the budget
every month but I mean what you I mean
you you kind of set it aside and then
came back to it right yes what made you
come back we weren't making any progress
okay you just didn't it didn't win 1:1
working no and you got tired of drowning
yes making you're working your butt off
and having nothing exactly 100
four thousand dollars you work through
that's impressive you guys we coulda
bought a house yeah he was really good
what what was the hardest part of this
for you all and public public public the
no-go stay on a bit of Buda budget and
then we also went from two cars to one
car and that was probably the hardest
thing for us because we were carpooling
to work and getting to work 5:45 in the
morning when he since he had to be at
work at 6:30 yeah what do you guys do
for a living at the time I was a teacher
and now I'm a stay-at-home mom and a
surrogate and now I'm working as a in
the in the kind of kind of caring person
okay very cool very cool you guys well
very well done I'm proud of you and you
brought three kids with you their names
and ages or what Thomas is 11 Alexandria
is three and Nolan is two awesomeness so
we had two kids during the time wow
that's amazing you know these are
debt-free kids yes that's pretty cool
I love it well how does it feel now that
you're completely debt-free great it's
so nice not to have so many payments
going out bad bad well congratulations
you guys I'm very proud of you thank you
very very well done we're gonna give you
a copy of Chris Hogan's number one
best-selling book retire inspired signed
by him because that's the next step now
yeah build that wealth and create that
incredible generosity opportunity that
you can do when you actually build some
wealth now that you're not paying out
all these debt payments so you got to
feel great guys we're proud of you
congratulations have the kids been
practicing yes they have all 12 hours
okay
all right a hundred and four thousand
dollars paid off in four and a half
years making sixty-five to seventy five
thousand a year count it down let's hear
a debt free scream three two one
way to go you guys man that's awesome
awesome job very very very well done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or $500,000 income